How often should I use the right ion pro wave to detox heavy metals or other things if there's such a thing as too much?
Well, I'd ever suggest using the ion pro wave more than one time a day.
That would be the maximum. Once a day would be the maximum on that.
Does the ion pro wave first, let's take a step back, does the ion pro wave really help detoxify heavy metals?
Yeah, I can. Are you going to pull a whole bunch of heavy metals out of your feet and into the water?
Not really. No.
The ion pro wave is understand the right ion pro wave is putting frequencies in and by putting frequencies through there you are affecting tissue and you do have some detoxification through your feet.
But all that change in color in the water isn't just a bunch of gum coming out of your body.
So let's not misinterpret that.
That's did there's other machines called ion cleanses.
There's a company called ion cleanse that started that machine. Now that's using that's actually it's called an ion cleanse because it's ionizing the water and a positive charge for a period of time is a negative charge.
Typically it's set at a 70 30 setting positive charge to negative charge. And therefore having that charge of the water is pulling the opposite ion out of your tissue more so than the ion pro wave.
So ion pro wave does a little bit of ionization. That's why it's going to pull some things but not as much as that other machine called the ion cleanse.
It's basically our code of makes one that is similar to that.
But that machine that company has both those companies have a very good reputation making quality equipment. They've been doing it for years.
But there can be benefit to using something like that to help help pull heavy metals.
But quite honestly, most heavy metals in your body are lodged in your tissues. They're not circulating in your bloodstream unless you have acute metal toxicity.
So if you did a blood test and you did your testing for heavy metals in your blood test, they would be negative unless you had acute exposure.
So meaning that somebody who just tried to poison you with arsenic and you got really super sick went into the emergency room.
It wouldn't be something they would normally do because most people don't get poisoned, right.
But if for some reason you had a very astute doctor that maybe listen to a family member that came in and said my mom's husband.
I think he killed his last wife or something. I don't crazy story and watch too much date line or something.
But and then they tested for that then you would have elevated arsenic in the blood and the treatment would be to put you on IV EDTA immediately.
So IV keylation immediately to pull that out of your blood.
But unless you had this this grow test exposure this high exposure to a heavy metal where you get heavy metals is is lower dose and lower dose heavy metals they're not going to stay in your blood for very long.
It's going to be pushed to your tissues and then it could you'll be pushed anywhere so can be pushed into cells that can be pushed in across the blood brain very especially this small particle heavy metals like you'd find in vaccines.
That's one of the major reasons why I'm so adamantly against vaccines is because the aluminum mercury that they do use and as an adjuvant in the vaccine.
They say really they the pharmaceutical company says there's no hard no foul in those because they're so small they're nano particles.
Well, nano particles of aluminum are even are far worse because they will cross the blood right barrier.
Matter of fact, it's just really interesting just reading an article today about how nano heavy medical metals are one major cause of neurological tables in Alzheimer's disease.
So neurological tables in Alzheimer's disease can be made up of heavy metals.
It can be made up of biotoxins like H by Laura and Borrelia burgodorphy and chlamydia pneumonia those are the three that they found in the study of biotoxins and then heavy metals aluminum mercury.
Most likely due to from vaccinations and these tables block neuronal flow and conductivity and that's what is also worse disease so you know heavy metals are a bad player in our body heavy metals are also one of the top four along with H by Laura causes of epithelial inflammation endothelial inflammation causing
heart disease.
So yeah, we want to get rid of heavy metals, but they're lodged in these tissues.
So the way you get rid of them is go back and look at the severed phases of detoxification pathways and you're supporting all these phases of detoxification and you really need to use ultimately a key later.
That's going to grab onto them help pull out of the tissues and you have to be do this slowly and be supporting all the phases of detoxification so that you're not just pulling about a one tissue and it can't get through the liver phase one phase two pathways because those are already blocked because you're not supporting that they already detoxing too many other things and then they just get deposited somewhere else so
it's real important to follow that pathway that's why so being on sawdust because sawdust is helping you detox through your skin and bypass the so the I am probably can help so don't give you wrong you have that tool use it but don't count that alone is all I'm saying.